and speaking of being thankful back here
at home over a thousand people directed
their admiration to the Red Rock Canyon
area this morning the popular hiking
spot has become even more popular during
this holiday weekend in recent years and
as Ryan Matthey shows us for different
reasons
beans greens potatoes turkeys pumpkin
pie that's the reward hikers here at Red
Rock Canyon say the idea take in the
hike before taking in the calories but
if not for that at least to take in this
view I'm thankful for oh my God all the
sediment that's created these rocks the
hike drive and climb now a holiday
tradition for some especially after
those Traditions were forced to change
over the past two years the best
climbers come here to like test
themselves on this rock like for these
three part of a larger climbing group
hitting some of the thousands of climbs
available we climbed for hours until we
got to the top of the spire and then got
to watch the sunset over the canyon and
it was just I mean this is what we
climbed for but there's some
pre-planning involved as the holiday
weekend remains one of the busiest the
few reservations available Wednesday
night disappearing by Thursday morning
representing over a thousand visitors on
Thursday alone this is really epic this
family from Canada making those
reservations early for a more than
special weekend well it was a Perpetual
engagement until we decided to come to
Vegas and decide to get married we're
from Illinois so there's not a whole lot
to look at and if not for any special
occasion at least to spend the day with
this unmatched View and those that mean
the most Thanksgiving all about family
right so we are here as a family thanks
spending time